[Musique]
c'est ce mercredi 18 mai qu'a été donné
le top départ de la 16e édition de la
fête de la nature piloté par le
département de la réunion au programme
des visites gratuites sur toute l'île
pour découvrir ou redécouvrir la
biodiversité réunionnaise comme ici à la
forêt de dioré à saint-andré donc
aujourd'hui on a une visite guidée de
l'espace naturel sensible comme
d'habitude mais on propose une animation
sur les oiseaux suivi au point de vue
d'un compte sur la légende des vaillants
chant et tout le long de la balade comme
d'habitude on va présenter la faune et
la flore du site nous avons les
discussions rien eu des plantations de
bois blancs donc c'est des espèces quand
même assez remarquable et on a quand
même six oiseaux protégés qu'on voit
tout le long de la balade donc c'est
vraiment mettre l'accent sur ce que
d'habitude il ne voit pas quand ils font
la marche encore mieux connaître les
espèces végétales et animales qui
peuplent les milieux naturels c'est tout
l'enjeu de cette opération les visiteurs
du jour ont eu droit à un atelier sur
les oiseaux forestiers endémiques de la
réunion alors dioré on peut rencontrer
la plupart des oiseaux forestiers dont
tels que le thé peut-être soit zola
vierge zoblazo vers le mail pays ou
encore
le pape en beauf est donc le seul un
rapace nicheurs donc l'idée c'est que
les gens les découvre bas leur régime
alimentaire leurs particularités et
aussi leurs habitants alors que les
promeneurs reprennent le chemin du
sentier de l'autre côté de l'île à saint
joseph un autre groupe s'apprête à
partir à la découverte du site de cap
blanc en propose des visites guidées au
public pour leur faire découvrir la
richesse floristique et faunistique et
culturel de ces différents espaces
naturels et du travail qui est fait par
le département et ses gestionnaires sur
le terrain pour remettre en valeur notre
patrimoine réunionnais donc ça fait une
quinzaine d'années qu'on travaille sur
ce site à revaloriser l'espace éliminer
les espèces envahissantes et redynamiser
un peu les espèces indigènes et
endémiques par l'élimination de ces
plantes exotiques donc on est là
vraiment pour
restaurer le milieu et permettre aux
gens d'évoluer dans un cadre le plus
agréable possible
pour finir cap sur la plaine des
palmistes à la forêt de la petite plaine
pour la fête de la nature il n'y a pas
que les agents du département et ses
partenaires qui se mobilisent
le conseil départemental des jeunes a
lui aussi eu son rôle à jouer alors ben
en fait on est conseiller des personnes
jeunes et en partenariat aujourd'hui
avec l'om est pour
faire une journée sensibilisation et des
touristes des gens qui viennent
pique-niquer pour
ramasser leurs déchets on va essayer
d'interpeller des voitures des fois
qu'elles ont elles sont tracées à aux
complices les interpeller mais en
général ils ont été réceptifs ils ont
dit que notre engagement et était bon
pour la nature était était noble on a eu
des personnes un peu moins réceptifs
d'autres personnes qui voulaient
discuter d'autres personnes qu'on embête
est assez évidemment mais qui n'en sont
pas moins écoutés c'est important de
ramener à la maison parce que ça peut
attirer les animaux des chats des rats
et c'est pas propre à près sur toute la
région minière de pique nique ça fait
des déchets partout c'est pas joli et ça
pollue la nature alors qu'on en a besoin
de la très nature propre une seizième
édition démarré sur les chapeaux de
roues et qui se poursuit jusqu'au
dimanche 22 mai au total ce sont près de
130 visites guidées et animations
pédagogiques qui sont proposées au
public pour s'immerger au coeur des plus
beaux sites naturels de notre île le
département de la réunion vous attend
[Musique]